what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back to talking thrones today I want to
discuss a topic that I once talked about
on my channel before maybe around 10
months ago I made a video about the
original outline george RR martin had in
mind for his epic fantasy series A Song
of Ice and Fire
some of you may be familiar with this
and some of you may not be over 20 years
ago back in 1993 actually George had
wrote a three-page letter that contained
the basic outline for the novels he
intended on writing for his story and in
this original draft there was some major
spoilers considering none of the books
had been published yet he went over some
of the major plot points he would have
and he also listed the five characters
that he intended on surviving the entire
series actually written down this letter
he wrote stayed private for over 20
years until someone from Waterstones
thought it would be a good idea to post
the pictures of this outline on Twitter
they eventually deleted the tweet but
not before someone screenshot the images
and spread it across the internet like
wildfire the reason why I want to talk
about this again today is because this
seems to be more relevant now than it
has ever been considering there is only
one season left of Game of Thrones and
since the television show is based off
of the books there is a good chance that
these five characters may survive the
entire television series also the
showrunners David and Dan have said on
multiple occasions that they basically
know how George intends on finishing his
story and for years they have also said
they know how they are going to end the
show so I can only assume they will both
in in a very similar fashion but it
won't be exactly the same even though
they are both taking their separate ways
to get to the ending there is a chance
the main characters will stay alive in
both the show and the books but there is
one major thing here you have to keep in
mind a lot of the stuff from this
original outline has changed it has kept
the same general theme but the majority
of the plot points he made never
actually happened
George ended up changing his mind and
going in different directions with some
things but either way I still find this
outline to be extremely fascinating I
have read this at least 5 different
times now and I still find it just as
interesting as I did the first time when
I read it in my opinion I believe the
five characters that he listed may no
longer be as safe as they once were but
I have been in a few debates about this
in the last couple days so what I want
to do is read to you this original draft
then we
talk about it some more afterwards
because there are a few more things I
want to say about it before I read this
I have to point out that whoever took
the photos of George's outline left the
blinds open behind them so you can see
the sun shining through the windows and
there are several glares across these
laminated sheets which makes it hard to
read some of this but what today's basic
technology there are ways to alter the
images to be able to read it all anyway
so I will do my best to translate to you
as much as possible so let's begin dear
Ralph here are my first 13 chapters 170
pages of the high fantasy novel I
promised you which I'm calling a game of
Thrones when completed this will be the
first volume in what I see as an epic
trilogy with the overall title a Song of
Ice and Fire as you know I don't outline
my novels I find that if I know exactly
where a book is going I lose all
interest in writing it I do however have
some strong notions as to the overall
structure of the story that I'm telling
in the eventual fate of many of the
principal characters in the drama
roughly speaking there are three major
conflicts set in motion in the chapters
enclosed these will form the major plot
threads of the trilogy intertwining with
each other in what should be a complex
but exciting narrative tapestry each of
the components presents a major threat
to the peace of my imaginary realm the
Seven Kingdoms into the lives of my
principal characters the first threat
grows from enmity between the great
house of Lannister and stark as it plays
out in a cycle of plot counter plot
ambition murder and revenge with the
Iron Throne of the Seven Kingdoms the
ultimate prize this will form the
backbone of the first volume of the
trilogy a game of Thrones while the lion
of Lannister and the dire wolf of Starks
Noro and scrap however a second and
greater threat takes shape across the
Narrow Sea where the Dothraki horselord
smash their barbarian hordes for a great
invasion of the Seven Kingdoms led by
the fierce and beautiful Daenerys
Stormborn the last of the Targaryen
dragons Lords
the Dothraki invasion will be the
central story of my second volume a
dance with dragons the greatest danger
of all however comes from the north from
the icy wastes beyond the wall where
half forgotten
demons out of legend the inhuman others
raised cold dead legions of the undead
and then never born and prepare to ride
down on the winds of winter to
extinguish everything that we would call
life the only thing that stands between
the seven kingdoms in an endless night
is the wall and a handful of men in
black called the Nights Watch their
story will be the heart of my third
volume the winds of winter the final
battle will also draw together
characters and plot threads left from
the first two books and resolved all in
one huge climax the 13 chapters on hand
should give you a notion as to my
narrative strategy all three books will
feature a complex mosaic of intercutting
points of view among various of my large
and diverse cast of players the cast
will not always remain the same old
characters will die and new ones will be
introduced some of the fatalities will
include sympathetic viewpoint characters
I want to read her to feel that no one
is ever completely safe not even the
characters who seem to be the heroes the
suspense always ranches up a notch when
you know that any character can die at
any time five central characters will
make it through all three volumes
however growing from children to adults
in changing the world in themselves in
the process in a sense my trilogy is
almost a generational saga telling the
life stories of these five characters
three men and two women the five key
players are Tyrion Lannister Daenerys
Targaryen in the three children of
Winterfell Arya brain in the bastard Jon
Snow
all of them are introduced at some
length in the chapters you have to hand
this is going to be I hope
quite an epic epic in its scale epic in
its action in epic in its length
I see all three volumes as big books
running about 700 to 800 manuscript
pages so things are just barely getting
underway in the 13 chapters that I've
sent you I have quite a clear notion of
how the story is going to unfold in the
first volume of Game of Thrones things
will get a lot worse for the poor Starks
before they get better
I'm afraid Lord Eddard Stark and his
wife Catelyn Tully are both doomed and
they will perish at the hands of their
enemies Ned will discover what happened
to his friend Jon Arryn but before he
can act on his knowledge King Robert
will have an unfortunate accident and
the throne will pass to his Sawin in
brutal son Joffrey still
minor Joffrey will not be sympathetic
and Ned will be accused of treason but
before he is taken he will help his wife
and his daughter Aria escape back to
Winterfell each of the contending
families will learn it has a member of
dubious loyalty in its midst
sons of Stark weds - Joffrey Baratheon
will bear him a son the heir to the
throne and when the crunch comes she
will choose her husband and child over
her parents and siblings a choice she
will later bitterly rue Tyrion Lannister
meanwhile will befriend bosons ax in her
sister Arya while growing more and more
disenchanted with his own family
young bran will come out of his coma
after a strange prophetic dream only to
discover that he will never walk again
he will turn to magic at first in hopes
of restoring his legs but later for its
own sake when his father
Eddard Stark is executed bran will see
the shape of doom descending on all of
them but nothing he can say will stop
his brother Robb from calling the
banners and rebellion all the North will
be inflamed by war and Robb will win
several spended victories in Maine
Joffrey Baratheon on the battlefield but
in the end he will not be able to stand
against Jaime in Tyrion Lannister and
their allies Robb Stark will die in
battle in Tyrion Lannister will besiege
and burn Winterfell Jon Snow the bastard
will remain in the far north
he will mature into a ranger of great
daring and ultimately will succeed his
uncle as the commander of the night's
watch when Winterfell burns Catelyn
Stark will be forced to flee the north
with her son bran and her daughter Arya
and hounded by Lannister Riders they
will seek refuge at the wall but the men
of the Nights Watch give up their
families when they take the black in Jon
and benjin will not be able to help -
Jon's anguish it will lead to a better
estrangement between Jon and bran area
will be more forgiving until she
realizes with terror that she has fallen
in love with Jon who is not only her
half-brother
but a man of the Nights Watch sworn to
celibacy their passion will continue to
torment Jon and Arya throughout the
trilogy until the secret of Jon's true
parentage is finally revealed in the
last book abandoned by the Nights Watch
Catelyn and her children will find their
only hope of safety lies even further
north
beyond the wall where they fall into the
hands of Mance Rayder the
king-beyond-the-wall and get a dreadful
glimpse of the inhuman others as they
attack the wildling encampment brains
magic Arya sword needle and the savagery
of their dire wolves will help them
survive but their mother Catelyn will
die at the hands of the others over
across the Narrow Sea Daenerys Targaryen
will discover that her new husband
the Dothraki called Drogo has little
interest in invading the Seven Kingdoms
much to her brother's frustration when
Viserys presses his claims past a point
of tact or wisdom called Drogo will
finally grow annoyed and kill him out of
hand eliminating the Targaryen pretender
and leaving Daenerys as the last of her
line Daenerys will bide her time but she
will not forget when the moment is right
she will kill her husband to avenge her
brother in flee with a trusted friend
into the wilderness beyond vast oath
rack Daenerys will be hunted by Dothraki
bloodrider x' but she will stumble in a
cache of dragons eggs the birth of the
young dragon will give Daenerys the
power to bend the Dothraki to her will
then she begins to plan for her invasion
of the Seven Kingdoms tyrion lanister
will continue to travel to plot and to
play the game of Thrones finally
removing his nephew Joffrey in disgust
at the boy Kings brutality Jaime
Lannister will follow Joffrey on the
throne of the Seven Kingdoms by the
simple expedient of killing everyone
ahead of him in the line of succession
and blaming his brother Tyrion for the
murders exiled Tyrion will change sides
making common cause with the surviving
Starks to bring his brother down and
falling helplessly in love with Arya
Stark while he's at it his passion is
alas unreciprocated but no less intents
for that and it will lead to a deadly
rivalry between Tyrion and Jon Snow
but that's the second book I hope you'll
find some editors who are as excited
about all of this as I am feel free to
share this letter with anyone who wants
to know how the story will go now if you
look at the bottom of the last page
George sent back in 1993 you can see
that there is about one paragraph
redacted something they didn't want
anyone else to see
but once again to some crafty people on
the internet they were able to decipher
some of this somehow
keep in mind I don't know how accurate
this is but this is what they were able
to decipher from the word
acted section of this letter if you look
on the screen now you can try to pause
this video and read it for yourself and
I'm not sure how accurate that might be
because that doesn't seem like anything
too secretive at this point most of the
things written there were already said
earlier in this draft so I don't know
why someone would try to hide it now but
you'd be the judge of that but there are
a few interesting things I wanted to
point out in this draft
George intended on having John and Aria
fall in love with each other and I know
some of you hate the fact that John and
Daenerys are falling in love because
they are obviously related but can you
imagine if John and Aria actually fell
in love I think that would be even worse
considering they grew up together in the
same house as brother and sister
although we all know they actually
aren't but what I wanted to show you is
how George actually said this would play
out he said John and arias passion for
each other will continue to torment them
until John's true parentage comes out I
think that is very interesting because
it says John and Arya will never
actually act on their emotions but when
his true parentage comes out then
something must happen he said it will
continue to torment them until his true
parentage comes out so does that mean
when they find out they aren't brother
and sister that they actually hook up or
does that mean something else like maybe
it rips them apart because John is
actually a Targaryen I'm wondering if he
still plans on doing some version of
this in the books
I doubt it ever happens in this show
because there isn't enough time and John
has already fell in love with Danny but
I thought that was an interesting way to
put it but it also says there would be a
love triangle between John Tyrion and
Arya it actually says this would turn
into a deadly rivalry between John and
Tyrion and we never even got a hint of
this in the television show or the books
yet but some people believe they may do
a version of this in the show ever since
Tyrion gave that look as John and
Daenerys were having sex on the boat
I've even seen some people say they may
do this deadly rivalry between John and
Tyrion over the love of Daenerys it did
appear that Tyrion was upset but I don't
actually believe it was because he was
jealous of John I think Tyrion must know
how this is going to complicate things
in the future
Tyrion may also feel his influence
slipping away even more now he's already
made enough bad decisions that has
Daenerys no longer taking his advice but
with her in love with John now she may
never listen to Tyrion again and instead
follow everything
john wants to do in tearing can sense
this may be happening sooner than later
but that's just my opinion as you can
see most of this draft has changed in
many ways george only planned on writing
three books to complete his series but
as we all know he wants to write seven
books now and they are all over 700
pages long which is what he was
originally thinking net and Caitlin
still died but not exactly how he had
planned Ned was never able to save
Catelyn and Arya by getting them back to
Winterfell Catelyn did not die beyond
the walls she died at the red wedding
and was resurrected as Lady Stoneheart
in Robb Stark never died on the
battlefield like he wanted either he
died at the red wedding too and I'm
actually glad the red wedding was done
the way it was instead it ended up being
one of the greatest episodes in
television history in my opinion Joffrey
was never maimed on the battlefield by
Robb either although that would have
been fantastic and Sons I never had
Joffrey's baby either thank the old gods
in the new Antarian never burned down
Winterfell Catelyn Arya and bran never
met John at the wall they never went
beyond the wall and met mance rayder
either and Daenerys never killed Khal
Drogo to avenge her brother's death
she didn't stumble across the dragon
eggs just lying somewhere either and
most of all Jaime never murdered anyone
to sit on the Iron Throne
could you imagine Jaime killing everyone
next in line to be on the throne and
actually blaming Tyrion for the murders
that would have completely changed
Tyrion and Jaime's relationship and I'm
glad it never went down like that but I
think that's enough examples as you can
see so much has changed and this leads
me to the most important question of
them all do you think the five central
characters George planned on having
survived the entire series still remains
the same
well Jon Daenerys Tyrion brain and arias
still make it through the end and
another question is will these
characters survive the entire Game of
Thrones series - George said he wanted
to write a story that made the readers
feel like no one is ever safe even the
heroes the drama in suspense really
ranch up an arch when you know that any
character can die at any time but even
with all that in mind he still wanted to
keep these five people alive no matter
what but in my opinion I don't think
they are all as safe as he once had
planned in the show it might be
different - because they haven't been
killing as many loved characters as they
use
- ever since they went off the books
they did kill Stannis and Lady Olenna
but even those deaths were done off
screen the biggest character they killed
was Jon Snow but they brought him right
back and that's even in the books
the only character that feels 100% safe
to me as Tyrion Lannister and I really
don't know why but he just seems to feel
like he will make it all the way through
I feel that way about Samwell Tarly - I
think they're going to be two of the
characters left over that will help
rebuild and restore Westeros and make it
great again but the other four
characters John Daenerys bran and Arya I
feel like they are in danger I think any
one of them can die in the last book or
the last episode and I don't know which
ones will die or how but I could easily
see John sacrificing himself or even
Brian having to sacrifice himself in his
powers to put an end to the night king
these are just my opinions though but
tell me how you feel about all this do
you believe they are still safe as
George intended or do you think any of
them can die now that he has changed so
many other things which ones do you
think will die or survive at the end of
the game of Thrones television series
let me know all your questions and
thoughts down below because I'm very
curious to see what the majority of you
have to say about this I want to thank
you all for taking the time out of your
day to watch the video I really
appreciate all of you for doing that and
I also want to thank my patreon
supporters - I hope you all have a great
day bye
you